I have to ask there's rumors you might
be working on a social network that's
text based that might be a competitor to
Twitter codenamed p92
is there something you could say
uh about those rumors
there is a project
you know I've always thought that sort
of a text based
kind of information utility
um
it's just a really important thing to
society and
for whatever reason I feel like Twitter
has not lived up to what I would have
thought its full potential should be and
I think that the current you know I
think Elon thinks that right and that's
probably one of the reasons why you
bought it and
um
and
I do that there are ways to to consider
alternative approaches to this and one
that I think is potentially interesting
um is this open and Federated approach
where you're singing with Mastodon I
mean you're seeing that a little bit
with blue sky and
I think that it's possible that
something that melds some of those ideas
with the graph
an identity system that people have
already cultivated on Instagram
could be a kind of very
welcome contribution to that space But I
don't know we work on a lot of things
all the time though too so I don't want
to get a get ahead of myself and we we
have we have projects that explore a lot
of different things and this is
certainly one that I think could be
interesting but so what's the uh release
the launch date of that again
or uh yeah what's the official website
and uh
but we don't have that yet oh okay but I
um all right and and look I mean I don't
know exactly how this is gonna turn out
I mean what I can say is yeah there's
there's some people working on this
right I think that there's something
there that that um that's interesting to
explore
so if you look at it'd be interesting
just to ask this question and throw
Twitter into the mix at the landscape of
social networks that is Facebook that is
Instagram
that is WhatsApp
and then think of a text-based social
network when you look at that landscape
what are the interesting differences to
you why do we have these different
flavors
and what what what are the needs what
are the use cases what are the products
what what is the aspect of them they
create a fulfilling Human Experience and
and a connection between humans that is
somehow distinct well I think text is
very accessible for people to transmit
ideas and to have back and forth
exchanges
um so it I think ends up being a good
a good format for discussion in a lot of
ways uniquely good right if you look at
um if some of the other formats or other
networks that have focused on one type
of content like Tick Tock is obviously
huge right and there are comments on
Tick Tock but you know I think the
architecture of the service is very
clearly that you have the video is the
primary thing and there's you know
comments after that
um and
um but I think one of the unique pieces
of having text-based comments like
content is that the comments can also be
first class and that makes it so that
conversations can just filter and Fork
into all these different directions and
in a way that's that can be super useful
so there's a lot of things that are
really awesome about the experience it
just always struck me
I I always thought that you know Twitter
should have a billion people using it or
whatever the thing is that
um that that that basically ends up
being in that space and for whatever
combination of reasons again it's it's
these are these companies are complex
organisms and it's very hard to diagnose
this stuff from the outside why doesn't
Twitter why doesn't a text based
comment as a first citizen based social
network have a billion users well I just
think it's hard to build these companies
so it's um it's not that every idea
automatically goes and gets a billion
people it's just that I think that that
idea coupled with good execution should
get there
um but but I mean look we hit certain
thresholds over time where
you know we kind of plateaued early on
and it wasn't clear that we were ever
going to reach 100 million people on
Facebook and then we got really good at
dialing in internationalization and
helping the service grow in different
countries and
um and and that was like a whole
confidence that we needed to develop and
um and helping people basically spread
the service to their friends that was
one of the things once we got very good
at that that was one of the things that
made me feel like hey if if Instagram
joined us early on then I felt like we
could help grow that quickly and same
with WhatsApp and I think that's sort of
been a core competence that we've
developed and been able to execute on
and others have too right I mean byte
dance obviously have done a very good
job with Tick Tock and and have um you
know reached more than a billion people
there but um but it's certainly not
automatic right I think you need you
need a certain level of of um of
execution to basically get there and you
know I think for whatever reason
I think Twitter has this great idea and
and sort of magic in the service
um but I I they just haven't kind of
cracked that piece yet and I think
that's made it's that you you're seeing
all these other things whether it's
Mastodon or
um or or blue sky
um that that I think are you know maybe
just different different cuts of the
same thing but you know I think through
the last generation of of um social
media overall
one of the interesting experiments that
I think should get run at larger scale
is what happens if there's somewhat more
decentralized control and if it's like
the stack is more open throughout and
um I've just been pretty fascinated by
that and seeing how that works
um
to some degree end-to-end encryption
um on WhatsApp and as we bring it to
other services provides an element of it
because it pushes the service really out
to the edges I mean the the
server part of this that we run for
WhatsApp
is relatively very thin compared to what
we do on Facebook or Instagram
and much more of the complexity is you
know and how the apps kind of negotiate
with each other to pass information in a
in a fully intent encrypted way
um but I don't know I think that that's
that is a good is a good model I think
it puts more power in individuals hands
and there are a lot of benefits of it if
you can if you can make it happen again
this is all like pretty speculative I I
mean I I think that it's it's you know
hard from the outside to know why
anything does or doesn't work until you
kind of take a run at it and
um
so I I think it's it's kind of an
interesting thing to experiment with but
I don't really know where this one's
going to go